well dangerous hurricane Maria is
marching towards Puerto Rico and the
Virgin Islands it made landfall on the
island of Dominica last night as a
category 5 storm the prime minister says
there is widespread devastation a second
hurricane Jose is expected to bring high
surf and rain to the parts of the
Northeast but Maria poses a much bigger
threat it is now a category 5 storm with
160 mile per hour winds
Jeremy cook with our partners at the BBC
is in Tortola one of the British Virgin
Islands waiting for a repeat assault
just two weeks after Hurricane Emma for
two weeks after the fury of Hurricane
Emma brought such devastation to these
communities the whole area is now braced
for misery upon misery because they've
been told that Hurricane Maria is
barreling towards the British Virgin
Islands what does it mean well with all
this wreckage on the streets every
single piece of wood and plastic and
metal becomes a potentially deadly
missile with winds again expected to
sustain at more than a hundred miles an
hour for people who've lost the rooms of
their houses of course it's a huge new
challenge the drains are blocked by
debris
there's expected to be really really
heavy rain and that means the potential
for flooding is self-evident and look up
there to the hills they're meant to be
green and lush and verdant but every
single leaf of every single tree you can
see is gone
that means the root structure is
weakened that means rain potentially
brings much light it's going to be a
very challenging week ahead challenging
indeed Jeremy Cook in the British
Parliament Virgin Islands thank you